ils ont entre 25 et 30 ans et sont
chargés de compétences clés au sein de
la nouvelle municipalité
l'investissement déjà élu lors du mandat
précédent anthony poulin tout juste
trentenaire incarne cette prime à la
jeunesse il a la responsabilité du
budget de la ville
192 millions d'euros ce que ça change
ces cas aussi des regards de neuf il ya
des vitalité qui vont s'exprimer
on est là pour transformer besançon et
avec une équipe jeune une équipe active
on transformera la ville la ville
emploie près de 1600 agents qui seront
sous la responsabilité d'élise et bishr
également conseillère régionale
elle réfute les soupçons d' incompétence
déjà lancés par l'opposition
mais des critiques dans deux ou trois
ans parce que j'aurai ma famille mon
boulot je l'entendrai partir du principe
que je vais jouer parce que je suis une
jeune femme de 26 ans aujourd'hui
confier d'importantes missions aux
jeunes élus anne vignot l'assument
la maire écologiste veut former la
relève sans créer de professionnels de
la politique
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai ça je leur dis
tout le temps moi je leur dis je vous
préviens c'est pour faites ce que vous
voulez dans la vie mais si vous faites
ça toute votre vie vous allez venir des
briscards de la politique
et ça je crois que personne n'en veut
plus que du coup quand tu feras ton
petit comme on anticipe vice présidente
de la communauté urbaine à
l'environnement et l'énergie
laurine gagliolo veut continuer à
travailler en plus de ses fonctions
d'élu et de sa vie de famille le vertige
il est double lasser c'est l'arrivée
dans la maternité l'arrivée dans le
mandat voilà ces deux grandes inconnues
de choses qui nécessitent des
aménagements très important dans une vie
donc voila mais je suis soutenu jeunes
rentre pas tout seul dans cette grande
aventure une aventure de six ans un
mandat pour imposer sa marque et prouver
qu en politique aussi la valeur n'attend
pas forcément le nombre des années